[Applaudissements]
je pense que dans pratiquement toutes
les séries des années 80 90 tous les
comédiens actuelle obama moi je fais
tous les méchants comme ça merci tu as
vu combien j'aimais bien les choses
mother l'expérience un peu étonnant
quand on sait pas ce qui fait qu vis là
c'était quoi ça c'était quoi cette
émission bah en fait je m'en souvenais
pas et c'est juste quelqu'un marot
montrer ça parce que maintenant on
retrouve tout avec ce revers des trucs
allergies internet et est alors je
pourrais très sincère je me souviens
plus très bien si ce n'est que je me
souviens que j'étais allé parce que
c'était un pote à moi car dugowson qui
est un musicien réalisateur et de ça
maintenant on a le même âge et il était
invité dans cette émission ils nous ont
demandé est ce qu'il y avait un copain
et on s'est retrouvés et alors je me
souviens plus franchement voilà 2 2 mais
c'était je pense que c'est déjà une
émission qui déjà à l'époque n'existait
pas je crois que c'était très calme à
gérer le moment le plus fin ce que vous
aimez kombustor diack a on aime bien ce
que cet acteur il est allé voir la
contrebasse
[Rires]